It is time to play
Are You Ready
For Some Fuzzball?!
(cheering)
Now, even though
I don't understand sports,
I still love the thrill of
victory and the agony of defeat,
so I want to fuse the excitement
of competition with a subject
that even the most indoors-y
of indoor kids can enjoy:
cute animal gifts!
Uh, so, does that sound good
to you, excitable kittens?
-Oh, sure it does!
-(others aw'ing)
-Aw...
-TOMPKINS: They're trapped!
(laughter)
Comedians,
I'm gonna show you an animal
about to attempt something
amazing, and for 250 points,
you have to call it
like it was a sporting event,
in your best
sideline reporter voice.
First up,
this enthusiastic squirrel.
And...
he's... oh, he's over the...
-KIRKMAN: Whoa!
-(laughter)
HARDWICK:
Paul.
And he's cleared the...
yes, he's cleared the fence,
and oh, good news
for the neighbor's dog,
finally getting his wish.
(laughter, applause)
Points.
-Jen. -Oh, I don't think
this was an accident.
He's been so depressed
since Sheila left him.
-(laughter)
-SKLAR: Yes. Yes. Yes.
-Very sports-like.
-So true. So true.
Good squirrel name,
too-- Sheila.
Can't take it anymore.
Sheila, why?
Is that Sheila next to him?
Would he do it
right in front of her?
-Oh, that... God.
-Yeah.
Next up, this comfy cat.
(bell dings)
Paul F. Tompkins.
Well, looks like curiosity
didn't kill the cat,
but a spinal injury did.
Points.
That's funny.
Next up, this pup struggling
with a flip-flop.
Aw, he's...
too stupid to get it in.
He's dumb. He's stupid.
-What a (bleep) idiot.
-SKLAR: Yeah, right?
Paul.
Well, he's having
just a little trouble
getting that flip-flop
through the door
after having successfully killed
and eaten Matthew McConaughy.
Points.
Next up, this sporty horsey.
Oh.
Yoga!
Oh. Randy.
And sadly, this is the final
nail in the coffin
of international horse pilates.
Paul.
And this is a very bold move
for an animal
with famously fragile legs.
Namaste, you (bleep) idiot.
Points.
Just get a regular office chair.
You're back'll be fine.
I'll give you points
for that one.
And finally, this dumb duck.
(babbling)
Paul.
And, just inches
from the finish line and...
Oh! He tries to swim away
from the ground.
Good thing...
good thing he's delicious.
-It really is like
he goes to default. -Yes.
Like, okay, what...
what do I know how to do?